yeah go into the bowl just put my ends
in it everything into the bowl good -
the see now get your garlic garlic I'm
gonna crush the garlic okay into the
spring onions the chiles good yeah
squish in there yeah that's it squeeze
now now now listen first of all
congratulations run in another mouthing
yes thank you very much for hours 13
minutes 22 seconds
Simon and peers they sponsored yes they
sponsor how much and Simon did a grand a
grant a grant
I know it's bits of the grant money so I
pasted one p extra one big one thousand
one one pence oh dear
that's to buy things Simon you should do
the London Marathon because you run
round it you've got your name on your
thing and everyone screams your name you
would love it they would definitely
write parsley just trim off the ends and
cut my understorms watch your fingers
you don't care okay now okay good now
you know when you got the job
okay on has Britain Got Talent yes yes
before for Simon did you audition no
Cheryl turned it down so I got the gig
Oh blue Peter they always had bowls
ready right water from the kettle or
sadena kettle okay in this master I get
to cook the pasta just fill up the
kettle halfway okay now a little safe
okay okay pasta don't keep it in the pan
on top of the stove good girl and just a
tablespoon of olive oil in there
huh I think the pans ha no that's the
short right that's a very hot pan now
that right okay now the pasta okay
there's any you take three minutes okay
that for you okay